hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher again one of the things it's
very particular to mathematics more than
perhaps any of the other subjects is our
obsession with getting the right answer
the single correct number that gets a
tick at the other end and I think we've
almost emotionally trained ourselves to
get a real catharsis out of yep there's
a number at the end it's very satisfying
but what's dangerous about that is that
I think it's it's commonly known in the
mathematical world that real problems
don't have just one solution so there
are multiple different ways to solve a
problem and actually usually the way
that you get there the reasoning process
that you go through and the
problem-solving strategies that you take
to arrive at that solution are so much
more important than the actual number
you get at the end something that I
think is very important here is the role
of Technology in this you know arriving
at the doing the calculation and
computation to arrive at that number is
valuable but increasingly now we are
having machines do this for us
now that really raises the question what
does it mean to be human what does it
mean to be a mathematician and a quote I
often come back to is that machines may
be for answers but humans are for
questions and if we don't take the role
of saying okay what is it that is
important here what do we want to know
then we're not going to be L think
mathematically and logically in the
world that surrounds us
[Music]